[Musique]
il était une fois un prince indien qui
cheminait à dos d'éléphant
son cortège rassemble certains des
nobles les plus puissants du pays
d'ici quelques minutes il va s'unir à
une princesse issue de l'une des plus
vieilles familles royales du sous
continent indien
[Musique]
ce mariage nous en avons suivi toutes
les étapes en coulisses depuis sa
préparation jusqu'aux cérémonies les
plus poignantes et les plus
confidentielles
[Musique]
quatre jours de voyage dans l'inde
éternelle
narrateur
[Musique]
l'histoire commence un mois plus tôt à
jay pour la capitale du rajasthan
une région dan qu'on appelle la terre
des rois célèbre pour ses palais
exubérant et c'est maharajah c'est ici
que va se dérouler le mariage
[Musique]
voici l'hôtel particulier des halles
sissach la famille du futur marié un
clan princier vieux de 500 ans
la résidence a récemment été transformé
en hôtel de luxe habib manyu le fils
aîné en est le directeur général
et aux chefs de préparer des repas pour
20 personnes pour le dîner
est lui aussi de décorer la table avec
des fleurs et des bougies et de sortir
le service en argent
comme les autres familles princières
indienne les halles sissach ont perdu
leur rang après l'indépendance du pays
en 1947 il a fallu trouver de nouvelles
sources de revenus cinq hôtels ont
ouvert depuis le second groupe hôtelier
du rajasthan
après l'indépendance ça a été très dur
pour nous
mon père m'a toujours dit tu as de la
chance de ne pas avoir connu cette
période
il faut que tu travailles dur pour se
regarder notre mode de vie de snacks et
des fêtes
d'ici quelques semaines habib magnon
mari son frère cadet drôme 26 ans
le directeur financier du groupe
familial
et c'est l'aîné qui se charge de
l'organisation de la noce il vient de
recevoir ce drapeau aux couleurs du clan
qui sera brandie lors du mariage
tu vois j'ai fait faire ce drapeau
miniature mais l'outil pas oublier de
tisser notre emblème au centre
ah oui c'est dommage
c'est le père de drouffe qui a choisi la
fiancée parmi plusieurs candidates un
mariage arrangé donc mais chez les
aristocrates indien c'est monnaie
courante alors le jeune homme est plutôt
serein je vais marier ça n'est pas rien
c'est sûr et tu n'es pas stressé non non
je ne suis pas stressé je me prépare
mentalement depuis longtemps
la seule chose qui le stresse c'est ce
qui va se passer après le mariage ils me
demandent toujours est-ce que je vais
devoir changer mes habitudes
la fiancée la voici en compagnie de sa
future belle soeur
queyranne 24 ans bien d'une des plus
anciennes familles royales du pakistan
un pays voisin c'est la cinquième fois
seulement que les deux jeunes gens vont
se rencontrer
bonjour queyranne comment savoir
bienvenue en inde bonjour queyranne
bonjour
mais pas question de se voir sans
chaperon
au menu du déjeuner l'organisation du
mariage et elle s'annonce compliquée
[Musique]
voilà le programme pas moins de quinze
cérémonies traditionnelles doivent
s'enchaîner pendant quatre jours car les
gens arrivent le dimanche puis un
premier rituel est prévu le matin
il ya ensuite la cérémonie de latika
suivi par le cocktail est le digne et
haineuse
car après le déjeuner il y aura encore
un rituel
pedrosa soit là puis il remonte sur
l'éléphant effet le rituel du toran la
jeune femme découvre des traditions dont
elle ignorait l'existence
ensuite queyranne du fera une danse
traditionnelle
devant tous les invités
m
oui je me sens prêt bats toi queyranne
non
je suis terrorisée j'ai peur de faire
une bêtise devant tout le monde
queyranne n'a plus qu'un mois pour se
préparer à son nouveau rôle de princesse
[Musique]
lever de soleil et de drapeaux sur le
plus grand des hôtels de la famille al
sissach choisi pour célébrer les noces
et affirmer la puissance du club
plus que quelques heures avant le début
des cérémonies
plusieurs centaines de serviteurs son
talent ouvrage
habima nous le frère aîné entame une
dernière tournée d'inspection
à toi et aux fleuristes de m'enlever cpo
je n'en veux aucun ici oui monsieur
l'objet de toutes les attentions c'est
cette salle du trône où va se tenir la
première grande cérémonie
mais attention c'est très fragile et ça
a énormément de valeur
au dessus de ses piliers en argent
massif va être tendu ce day qui
appartient la famille depuis plus de 120
ans comme vous pouvez le voir s'est
hissé en fils d'or et en fils d'argent
c'est un symbole de richesse et de
prestige
il faut être très précis car beaucoup de
nos invités vont scruter le moindre
détail nous n'avons pas le droit à
l'erreur il faut qu'il se dise
le père du marié un ancien officier de
l'armée indienne vient contrôler la
bonne marche des opérations
où est le chef d'equipe
il est allé chercher un outil
fait vraiment attention
ici aura bientôt lieu la remise de
cadeaux par la famille de la mariée
alors à l'autre bout du palais le plan
de queyranne se prépare à tenir son rang
pause les cas de là bas la tante de la
jeune femme a prévu plusieurs dizaines
de cadeaux sans lésiner sur la dépense
comme ses vêtements traditionnels cousu
main
ses vêtements ont été réalisés par un
tailleur très connu à jaws pour toutes
les grandes familles sa vie là bas
le futur marié va recevoir ces parures
d'or et d'émeraude
et sept montres de luxe sertie de
diamants à 15000 euros ça c'est en or et
en argent à l'intérieur il ya de vrais
noix de coco
il y en a pour plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros au bas mot
j'ai vraiment acheter ce qu'il ya de
mieux et vous pensez qu'ils vont aimer
j'espère bien j'ai travaillé dur
la noce va commencer près de 500 invités
se dirige vers la salle du trône en
tenue d'apparat allez vous asseoir ça va
débuter
plusieurs maharaja sont présents les
anciens rois de l'inde
mais la plupart des invités sont des
aristocrates ils appartiennent à la
caste guerrière derradj pout encore très
puissante en inde leurs symboles l'épée
et le turban
les cadeaux ont été disposés au centre
de la salle les deux clans se font face
ne manque plus que le marié
dans la pièce voisine dernières
directives aux membres de l' escort
mettez vous bien en ligne et ne rompait
pas les rangs il faut que tous vos
accessoires soient bien visibles
le futur marié arrive seul c'est la
tradition il ne découvrira queyranne
qu'au moment de la cérémonie religieuse
et ce sont les hommes de la
belle-famille qui apporte les cadeaux
[Applaudissements]
félicitations merci merci
chaque aristocrate prend ensuite hommage
au jeune prince à coude enveloppes
remplies de billets
[Musique]
la cérémonie a de la lure le père du
futur marié triomphe
[Musique]
fin de la première journée autour d'un
cocktail
[Applaudissements]
la belle famille a été à la hauteur le
père de queyranne a le sourire aux
lèvres pour l'instant demain il marie sa
fille
mais moi
au petit matin le jour suivant karan
débute sa transformation en princesse
raj coûte
dernier prélude avant le grand saut
ma vie va changer je le sais dans ma
belle famille ils sont trés mandants ils
sortent tout le temps avant je vivais
une existence plutôt simple donc ça va
être un vrai changement pour moi
début de l'habillage avec des parures
transmises par les deux familles des
bijoux parfois centenaires pas toujours
bien ajuster
sa courageuse ma fille
c'est une vraie torture non
ce sont des diamants autour d'une perle
et derrière c'est de l'or
on appelle ça le mans 10
c'est une parure traditionnelle pour la
tête
de l'or des diamants par dizaines 40
c'est que la valeur de ces parures est
inestimable
je sens vraiment le poids des bijoux sur
moi c'est très lourd mais je les trouve
tellement beau je vais tenir le prouve
combien il vaut le collier à ton avis
entre 15000 et 30000 euros facilement
dernière étape le voile traditionnelle
karan doit rester caché aux yeux de tous
jusqu'à la fin du mariage
[Musique]
à l'autre extrémité du palais son fiancé
par rejoindre la jeune femme à dos
d'éléphant privilège royal
la procession des buts avec plusieurs
centaines de nobles raj foot en grande
tenue exactement comme il ya cinq cents
ans
les jeunes femmes immortalisent le
moment sur leur téléphone portable
[Musique]
le frère aîné du marié qui a tout
organisé savoure le spectacle
le grand moment est arrivé je suis très
heureux bien sûr et très fier aussi
place maintenant à la cérémonie
religieuse seule la famille de queyranne
et ses amis peuvent y assister ses
meilleures copines sont impatientes de
voir ça
les couleurs c'est magnifique et j'adore
les bijoux ils sont très beaux
incroyable
le prêtre hindou comment ces prières en
langues sont inscrits l'équivalent de
notre latin mais en inde pas des changes
de bagues ni même de consentement ce
sont avant tout deux familles deux clans
qui s'unissent
la tante de cairanne attache les mains
du couple avec un foulard il tourne
ensuite plusieurs fois autour du feu
sacré ensuite seulement ils seront
mariés
[Musique]
ce spectacle sera attise la curiosité de
ses invités venus du pakistan
c'est incroyable de voir ça
c'est une expérience qu'on fait une
seule fois dans sa vie je suis vraiment
heureux d'être là
donc maintenant tu devras la protéger
avec ton épée
drum et queyranne sont désormais mari et
femme
la fête peut commencer
[Musique]
pendant que le jeune homme profite du
spectacle
une dernière épreuve attend la princesse
dans la chambre nuptiale karan se
prépare à danser devant les femmes de
son nouveau clan
votants comme ça tout simplement
pas aussi haut les bras
et elle n'est pas vraiment au point
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie c'est
la première fois
j'angoisse tellement j'ai vraiment peur
de tomber devant tout le monde
un peu plus tard la salle du trône est
pleine
toutes les femmes sont venues voir le
visage de la nouvelle princesse
et surtout la voir danser un spectacle
interdit aux hommes
[Musique]
les premiers mouvements sont timides mal
assurée
mais très vite les femmes de son nouveau
clan l'entourent et lui rendent hommage
[Musique]
oubliez les doutes et les peurs
la jeune pakistanaise
réussi son rite de passage
alors le lendemain au moment de
rejoindre le foyer de son mari son coeur
n'est plus si lourd
[Musique]
queyranne la fille unique fait ses
adieux aux siens
mais ce sont ses parents qui souffrent
le plus
nooja l'effort c'est un nouveau voyage
un nouveau départ avec un nouveau foyer
dans un nouveau pays
donc prions pour que cela se passe au
mieux pour elle
le père de cairanne l'espère le prince
et la princesse al sissach vivront
heureux et auront beaucoup d'enfants
comme dans un conte de fées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]